today Fox News Alert I'm Bret Baier
House Democrats are throwing down
another gauntlet tonight in the
increasingly bitter battle over the
Muller report there would be point man
for impeachment Judiciary Committee
Chairman Jerry Nadler has subpoenaed a
key White House insider and a featured
player and the special counsels
narrative former White House Counsel Don
again is the subject of that subpoena
we're awaiting response from the Trump
team chief White House correspondent
John Roberts starts us off tonight with
that breaking news good evening John
Brett good evening to you and we are
still awaiting a White House response
it's unknown at this point if the White
House will claim executive privilege and
keep McGann from testifying it's also
unclear at this point how much more
Congress could learn from McGann that
isn't already known remember the special
counsel Robert Muller interviewed McGann
for some 30 hours and found no concrete
evidence of any kind of consumed
obstruction of justice but this is the
latest in a blizzard of subpoenas that's
expected to come down off of Capitol
Hill that while it may fall short of
impeachment will no doubt continue to
tie the White House in knots
at the annual Easter Egg Roll today
President Trump weighed in on talk of
impeachment taking a what me worry
approach at the moment the president's
confidence would seem to reflect the
thinking at the Democratic leadership in
a letter to her colleagues today House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi writing while our
views range from proceeding to
investigate the findings of the Moller
report or proceeding directly to
impeachment we all firmly agree that we
should proceed down a path of finding
the truth it is also important to know
that the facts regarding holding the
president accountable can be gained
outside of impeachment hearings the
chairman of the committee that would
take up impeachment appeared to hesitate
when asked about it this is impeachable
yeah I do I do think that this if proven
if proven which hasn't been proven yet
some of this if proven some of this
would be impeach about yes but while
some 20 20 Democratic candidates have
stayed away from any talk of impeachment
senator Elizabeth Warren perhaps seeking
a boost to her leg and campaign said
she's all in President Trump mocked such
talk in a tweet today firing back only
high crimes and misdemeanors can lead to
impeachment there were no crimes by me
no collusion no obstruction so you can't
impeach it was the Democrats that
committed the crimes not your Republican
president the president was also on
offense on the financial front today
suing House Oversight Committee Chairman
Elijah Cummings for trying to subpoena
financial records from the Trump
organizations accounting firm Meszaros
USA in the lawsuit Trump attorneys
attacking the subpoena writing its goal
is to expose plaintiffs private
financial information for the sake of
exposure with the hope that it will turn
up something that Democrats can use as a
political tool against the president now
and in the 2020 election sources say the
subpoena goes well beyond requests for
the president's financial records also
seeking those if all of his children
including Baron and Tiffany Trump the
lawsuit claims the subpoena was issued
because Michael Cohen a felon who has
pleaded guilty to lying to Congress told
the House Oversight Committee that the
president had misrepresented his net
worth while he was a private citizen
Cummings appeared unfazed by the legal
action in a statement this afternoon
saying the president has a long history
of trying to use baseless lawsuits to
attack his adversaries but there is
simply no valid legal basis to either
fear with this duly authorized subpoena
from Congress the president's attorneys
insist that his finances have long been
under the scrutiny of a federal agency
the Internal Revenue Service that it's
the IRS is purview not Congress's to
look into people's financial records
they also point out that the IRS has
looked at President Trump for years upon
years and is so found no reason to bring
any kind of action civil or criminal
against the president breath now John
Chairman Nadler dropped this subpoena
for da McGann as House Democrats are
meeting on this conference call about
next steps after the Muller report the
White House did not hold back did not
have issue executive privilege for any
of the Muller report over the testimony
of McGann before is there a thought that
they may step up again and do that I
mean we don't know if they're going to
exert executive privilege in the case of
Don Magan testified before Congress but
remember the entire Muller investigation
was contained under article 2 of the
Constitution which is the executive
branch so really it was done McGann a
member of the executive branch talking
to another member of the executive
branch when it came to the Moller
questioning but if Congress were to
subpoena him then that's article 1 of
the Constitution against article 2 of
the Constitution so I assume that the
president under that premise would be
able to exert executive privilege it
would be somewhat different but the
point is that they did not exert
executive privilege over the release of
the Muller report so because they didn't
do that there may be a problem and
trying to put the toothpaste back of the
tooth the toothpaste back in the tube
now but in terms of whether it's they
didn't exert executive privilege for
McGann talking to Muller that's within
the administration this is different
because it's the
and Congress to different branches of
government unchartered waters
either way John thank you